哈喽哈喽，
我第一次来华强北，
下这么大的雨，
我们要更新我们的设备，
妈耶，
今天我们好不容易过个周末，
要下大雨了，
完了完了，
深圳今天这天气啊，
师傅应该是车上经常会背着伞，
对吗？
对呀，
那这样挺方便的，
好一会儿我们就买，
买两把大姐，
因为人家大哥先说送我们，
给我们分一把伞来着，
对，
我心想那我们就买两把，
大哥说他有一个朋友是卖伞的，
下雨天买伞，
晴天的卖万来啊，
下晴天卖气球，
下雨天卖伞，
这挺好，
都有生意做诶，
挺好，
我在深圳人均三个工作，
你怎么把袜子都脱了下气。
这样的话，
下雨的话，
你就还可以当一个雨湿雨鞋去扶一下，
我们真得在大哥这儿买伞了，
你看这雨天了，
还没下车就已经小，
大哥雨下大了，
你会不会成为雨伞刺客，
我相信大哥一定不会刺我们的两次3那大的多少啊1哦，
那行，
那可以拿两把大的，
大哥我看一下50块钱就把它质量怎么样啊，
这样吧，
你直接个30的啊，
这是30的啊啊50的吗？
啊，
只有两把，
你只有两把是吧？
大哥哦两哦，
好，
我那我怎么扫，
我扫你扫那个微信30是吧？
啊，
这是我们刚才跟大哥买的伞，
30块钱其实很好了，
这个30块钱的伞就已经很大了，
什么吴国那边有一个大美女在等。
的话，
你们不会就抛弃了，
我俩也没呀，
我想去洗个头，
我已经好几天没洗了，
OK,
我，
你把我包放起来。
怎么样怎么样怎么样飘逸，
可以啊，
可以，
我先透明一下用的什么洗发水，
这个时候应该差不多一个，
是啊，
我我第一次来华强电子世界，
你听这明应有尽有，
看直播间灯光解决方案，
我们来就是奔这里来的哦，
好不多种耳机啊，
也不便宜啊，
100多块钱可砍，
他可以砍一刀打，
咦，
这个东西你该说说了，
这有创意，
你看上了，
功能比较辣眼，
你消。
里要不要一个，
你这个价你哥不足不管，
还得说我掌管心大，
去吃饭吗？
我们吃什么？
你们上次不是说特别好吃那个地方吗？
腰花那家是吧？
对啊，
要不去吃那家好，
刚刚给姐推荐了一家最好吃的生菜川菜，
姐请客，
姐消费，
姐买单。
哎，
出来一天了，
没有人认识了，
快，
我认识，
我们全部都已经空盘了，
我先上秀下，
哎，
吃，
我也为经上个厕所，
哎，
你们都走姐吃完饭我知道了，
我们去腐败腐吧按摩，
我主要想按摩腰好，
可以腰关肩膀来个方式按摩好鱼摩吧，
还力度中的轻了，
跟我说啊，
想让是阳光下我怎么听到英语，
我是在听英语啊，
太卷了吧，
这我在学习英语啊，
一往下讲，
你们是在学英英语啊，
我说你们是。
你还是个学生，
我是你没说你比我小你多大叔我我肯定比我肯定大了，
我你多大吧，
我我就是你们，
你们这是你这叔叔来很大的，
80后的，
我84年，
我84年不可能啊，
真的我真我那看到他好小，
一定要下来，
跟你们三个在一起很融洽，
所以就过得很开心，
他很年轻，
我们一个人我感大哥你是有感觉，
你说我们三个人跟我们是年轻大哥没有那么多弯弯绕绕，
人家大哥就随口就说的，
看看我们的钱都花到哪里去了，
我们攒了好久的快递，
今天统一还拆一次好不好了，
还有点水，
像流水线上班一样，
流水线这是我给宝宝买的吧，
因为我这裤子有点。
长的吧，
100码的，
这个是我要看一下是不是哦，
这是我的牛仔裤吧，
嗯，
还有这么多啊，
但是哎呀，
这聪明他给我寄了一这个风扇，
可以直接放在桌子上对着吹，
可以吹出你的头发的飘逸，
头发小的人会不会吹头吹出你的粗头，
那你这是这种的风扇啊，
这个是我的，
你们猜是什么？
它应该不是个枕头，
它是一个腰枕，
就专门用来枕腰部的一个东西，
就睡觉的时候把它放在腰的，
这不会是你的吧？
看一下你应该穿不上哦，
这个是宝宝的防晒衣，
很可爱。